elle serait toujours dans le coma au
CHRU de Tours une blezoise de 24 ans est
entre la vie et la mort après
l'agression dont elle a été victime dans
son immeuble mardi dernier une tentative
de meurtre de la part de son
ex-compagnon la jeune femme était
pourtant venue porter plainte quelques
heures plus tôt ou commissariat de Blois
pour des faits de violence de menaces et
du harcèlement mais elle n'a jamais été
entendue par un policier Florent Clavel
à la demande de la préfecture l'IGPN est
donc en ce moment à pied d'oeuvre dans
les locaux du commissariat de Blois
derrière moi objectif de la police des
polistes tenter de comprendre pourquoi
la victime n'a pas pu porter plainte au
moment où elle s'est présentée deux
heures plus tard elle était violemment
agressée par son ex-conjoint une
question maintenant sur toutes les
lèvres ce drame aurait-il pu être évité
si la jeune femme avait été prise en
charge par les fonctionnaires impossible
à dire pour cette responsable d'une
association féministe elle pointe
néanmoins l'importance du recueil
immédiat de paroles dans les cas de
violence faites aux femmes la loi oblige
à ce que la plainte soit prise l'idéal
ça aurait été de vérifier qu'elle
n'était pas en danger imminent et qu'il
fallait la mettre en sécurité alors l'on
se parle la victime de 24 ans est
toujours hospitalisée à Tours elle se
trouve entre la vie et la mort le drame
remonte à mardi dernier la victime veut
déposer plainte contre ses textes
conjoints qui lui a fait subir des
violences tentatives infructueuses donc
de retour chez elle la jeune femme
croise son bourreau présumé au pied de
son immeuble il veut des explications
après la rupture et l'avortement décidé
par elle la discussion dégénère et c'est
là que l'homme de 27 ans lui assène de
violent coup à la tête ce voisin a
alerté les pompiers
chez moi pour me dire de descendre pour
rouler la porte
car vous j'ai pu ni rien on y parlait ma
bouche j'ai vu on appelait les pompiers
et puis voilà le suspect est connu de la
justice pour des faits de violence
antérieure en garde à vue il a reconnu
les coûts mais ni avoir voulu tuer son
ex-conjointe il a été mis en examen pour
tentative de meurtre et écroué